supermodel Tatiana petites has died she
was 56 years old
[Music]
it's all the perspective you know it's
from the artist news of Tatiana's death
was first announced by Vogue who helped
launch the iconic fashion model's career
the cause of death has not yet been
released
I'm a model I've worked in the fashion
business for a long time I was born in
Hamburg Germany and I grew up in Sweden
Tatiana Rose to Fame in the late 80s and
90s eventually considered one of the
original supermodels each person sees a
woman or portrays a woman and
differently yeah differently and it's
it's just a beautiful portraits that's
what I like to say more than shots you
know just beautiful portraits no
stranger to the camera she made herself
a home in the pages of magazines like
British Vogue Marie Claire and
Cosmopolitan even appearing on the cover
of Vogue six times that's where the
relationship comes in like how long have
you known a photographer certain
photographers make you feel comfortable
where you don't feel you know like it's
a big deal fans may also remember
Tatiana from her appearance in George
Michael's hit music video freedom 90.
we have to
have to do now
take these lies
alongside her Tatiana's fellow OG models
Christy Turlington Linda Evangelista
Naomi Campbell and Cindy Crawford
despite her growing Fame Tatiana seemed
to never get comfortable with all the
attention that came with it no it's not
something I'm used to and I I don't know
what to think of it actually while in
her later years Tatiana lived a private
life mostly out of the spotlight she'll
be remembered for her iconic work and
Legacy in the fashion world I think
style is Ageless because it's about
identity and self-expression
[Music]